What you're about to see are not paintings on canvas.
They are real people painted to create the illusion of two-dimensional paintings.
LA-based artist Alexa Meade turns her subjects into works of art.
She paints on people in three-dimensional spaces...
...in such a way to give the illusion they are two-dimensional paintings.
And she can take a photograph of her subjects from any angle...
...and they look flat.
Alexa was a self-taught artist and she developed her style thanks to her interest in shadows.
Alexa said,...
...I didn't know that I would end up being an artist...
...and then all of a sudden, I came up with this idea.
I wondered what it'd look like to put black paint on the shadows...
...and then I realized that if I put paint on top of things in the real world,...
...I can make them look like a two-dimensional painting.